speaking of babies though it was the
birth of her twin babies that prevented
Beyonce from performing at Coachella
last year and the time has finally come
she's here to make good on her work she
will be performing the next two weekends
at the Coachella Music Festival I will
be there Desiree will be there Sophie
covers music we got a preview for you
guys like no other will not be there no
she will not be pregnant
help us like with set up the context of
Coachella because it is a California
festival but it is so major now and
everyone talks about everyone cares
about it it was a huge deal I think no
matter where you are in the country
you've probably heard of it and you've
definitely heard of the headliners we've
got the weekend Beyonce Eminem hello no
big deal so last year alone they had 99
thousand to a hundred and twenty five
thousand people just on the ground
attending the festival itself there's a
lot of people so people come from all
over the world to be a part of this
because it's so much more than the music
I think you guys both know firsthand it
is an experience all around and if you
can't be there in person they also live
stream it on YouTube and they're live
streaming on Sirius XM radio as well so
even if you can't get to the desert you
can still be a part of all the fun right
yeah you know a lot of artists will say
performing at a festival like Coachella
is a career highlight so I think they
also come guns blazing you know they're
like ready to really show off their
music and do something special special
for that crowd and I think it's on a lot
of people's bucket list
New York and it's crazy to me how over
the years everyone is talking about
Coachella you know they started sharing
who's performing and they're like I want
to make it to this festival one year and
it doesn't matter if you're from a
smaller big city everyone knows what
Coachella is everyone except cardi B
except cardi B cardi B who of course is
expecting is performing at Coachella
this year on Sunday but take a look at
this clip from an interview with Sirius
XM you guys where she explains she
didn't really fathom how huge Coachella
is take a look like we've been booked
Coachella like six months ago Simon
I'm getting paid for Coachella like 70
Bandos a day yeah they get in it they
get in the look so it is that I did not
like I been got booked for this and then
it's like I have to invest so much money
on my stage set my own money that I
gotta go to Wells Fargo and write a
check that is crazy like almost 300 300
L thought I was dropping a lot of money
at Coachella like that's the most inside
ever gotten about Coachella from an
artist is performing at Coachella I've
never heard of monetary figures before
so good on you cardi B we like that dirt
through the math she says she's getting
$70,000 but her states that was costing
her nearly three hundred yeah so I mean
it's that important for something that's
a career it's you know it's gonna come
back to her because there's a huge
publicity this is a big big moment for
her
speaking of comeback so like I said that
Beyonce is headlining the festival but
honestly it's a huge deal because this
is her first time performing since
giving birth to the twins we last saw
her on stage at the 2017 Grammy Awards
and this has been a over a year in the
making again she couldn't make it last
year because she was expecting the twins
Lady Gaga filled in for her and now
she's here and she's reportedly putting
in 11 hours of rehearsal time we've also
heard that she's hired 90 new backup
dancers so she's putting in the work and
she they're just going to storm the
stage it's just incredible choreography
which I know you talked to her
choreographer absolutely yeah we
actually talked to her lead
choreographer to quell night at the time
you couldn't give me too much but you
know what he gave me just enough you
guys take a look at what your to Cal
sweat excuse me Jack well says is gonna
be a career-defining moment for her be
ready for a good time yeah I have a good
old time we're getting ready for
Coachella and you know that's gonna
change the game and super excited what's
one word you can tease to describe her
Coachella performance one word amazing
beyond iconic life like
before thank you
we were just trying to figure out like
how big the stage is gonna be first how
she's gonna fit all the dancers on the
stage yeah go as she will find a way and
I what I do know is the set times came
out for Coachella performing before her
on Saturday at the main stage is Higham
and there's literally an hour gap
between hi I'm and Beyonce so I mean so
what do you do you know what you try and
push your weight but you try getting
motivation are you trying to Beyonce
sometime note I'm gonna be following you
on Instagram as you should
I will actually I was gonna mention this
at the end but I'm taking over
entertainment tonight's Instagram story
on Saturday well at D director and at
Entertainment Tonight because I'm gonna
keep it lit guys don't you worry you
can't be there and doing a lot of
Beyonce posts watch the show you know
I'm a fan um some other things to expect
I mean I guess appearance it only makes
sense don't you think yeah I mean I
think fans would be a little upset if he
didn't show up especially because they
just announced they're on they're on to
tour so I think they'll give fans a
little preview of what's that's gonna be
and also I would love to see Beyonce
shock us and surprise us with maybe some
new music I think it's been a good time
yes it's time because we've seen all of
her everything that she has out we've
seen live already right so and we all
know Beyonce likes a surprise drop
exactly is this you like emblematic of
that now that's music anymore but now we
expect surprises like that and we also
know guys from jay-z himself in a recent
interview with The New York Times that
lemonade was originally gonna be a joint
album a collaborative album with him he
says that music still exists we know
we're sitting on some joint music
whether it's a whole album I don't know
but I'm expecting them hopefully to drop
something new together especially now
that on the run to has been announced
like I would wouldn't put it past them
to drop some new music together I can
see that happening and also like blue
Ivy is going to be around for the tour
as well as the twins yeah and I know
Blue Ivy has her vocals on some of these
tracks with Jay so maybe you shall get a
little onstage appearance that'd be
crazy I love that and you know obviously
they're gonna try and sell tickets
further on the run tour without a doubt
but I would hate for this to become the
Beyonce and jay-z show like it's her
night I think maybe bring Jay out for
one song yet tease the tour yes that's
fair no this is her shining moment for
sure he did bring her out for his
headlining set Coachella in 2009 so I'm
just saying return the favor for a
little fun and I would be awesome if
they did a new song fingers crossed
one thing we're I think everybody or
every huge Beyonce fan is holding now
for is also a Destiny's Child reunion
see this is my thing I'm like they did
it for Super Bowl are they gonna do it
again I don't think so my gut says yes
and let me tell you why it is the 20th
anniversary of Destiny's Child debut
album you know with the announcement of
all the run to I don't imagine that
Destiny's Child will be doing a reunion
tour anytime soon this would be the
perfect stage and setting for her to
bring them out and and and celebrate how
far they've come
I mean that's where she started she
started singing when she was nine years
old does his child have been and now
look at her like I feel like this is the
setting for that to happen and I know
you actually reported this in one of the
articles up on et online about Beyonce
but there's been some fan speculation
about this Destiny's Child or you guys
have been on it there's been a very very
stealthy member of the band hive who
basically posted all these cryptic posts
from not just Michelle Williams of
Destiny's Child but the two founding
members latavia and latoya again listen
beyonce is all about female empowerment
and what a sign of solidarity amongst
her girls by bringing them all on stage
for this moment i think it could happen
i don't know it's all speculative
for now but fingers crossed wouldn't it
be cool she needs a headline out of this
right
oh I feel like hers will be oh I see you
know an hour and a half maybe less maybe
a little less than that yeah because I
don't know if there's a curfew or not
but right that's plenty of time yeah
she's on at 11:05 p.m. Saturday Pacific
so two men y'all will be luxury no
breakdown for you the age bracket I'm
not 22 anymore yeah I mean as you
mentioned there is a lot of different
people who go to Coachella for around
the world there's also a bunch of ages I
mean I've seen kids there yeah I've seen
kids there I've seen older people there
for sure there is no cut off you know
however I know I'm being a little too
old for this as far as like I can do the
recovery is not the same you guys yeah
and I'm covering it for et this weekend
I got a like hydrate yeah I'm tired it's
a fun time everybody before we go though
you guys it's not all about Beyonce or
the other headliners the weekend and
Eminem we also have our picks where
other acts
if you're in the desert or watching the
live stream you should check out who
aren't the headliners you want to kick
us off des sure so obviously cardi B if
you're not going for her music at least
go for a peek at that baby bum I mean
she finally confirmed the news that
she's pregnant with amigos is offset and
seriously I'm looking forward to that
because she just dropped a brand new
album invasion of privacy oh sorry yeah
we just saw a Chanel she's got amazing
music so I'm looking forward to that and
I think Miko's is set like I think
they're gonna cross over and perform at
each other sides it would be a
ridiculous not to and in that little
interview clip of cardi that we played
for you guys in that same interview she
also talked about how she's putting in
10-hour rehearsals of the day I also
think it's cuz she's cramming it in to a
couple of days but she's been busy she's
been in New York she did SNL to LA yes
yesterday yeah so she's so she's putting
in the work as well I saw angel over
here on Facebook saying he's excited to
see cardi B we are too I mean I'm
definitely gonna be that although um
also I saw that she's only performing
for 35 minutes really I mean I know
she's pregnant but I was like 35 you got
a whole album play I need to hear it I
need to hear I'm sure whatever
her and me goes like between the two I
think we could see a lot of cool
appearances I mean they have
collaborated with Nikki I don't know
should we be there but dj khaled like
there's a lot of people that we couldn't
see shot Pharrell who always at
Coachella yeah well and also on the
album invasion of privacy cardi
collaborated with scissor with Kalani
that's another person you guys should
check out another breakout artist of
last year I've never seen her live a lot
of you guys have it so definitely check
her out right I'm also excited for
Miguel I'm a huge Miguel fan I feel like
he's super underrated he came in big
with a door on one Grammy won a Grammy
he did the Coco soundtrack this last
album was really good I love his voice
and if you guys are in the desert go
check him out because not only does it
have this sweet falsetto he knows how to
throw a party on stage like he really
does he's super cares oh ya know and his
voice is amazing so that's another
person I'm excited about yeah and I
gotta say so because the lineup is so
like hip-hop heavy this year I was
actually pretty stoked to see that there
are still are some EDM artists and rock
bands on there one that I'm really
looking forward to is this girl that
she's an Australian DJ and she goes by
the stage name Alice in Wonderland and I
think she's just so rad like if you
haven't checked her out please do if
there's a remix called new rules it's of
course dually puss and it is bomb and I
just think it's gonna be so great and
she is actually the highest billed
female DJ Coachella has ever had reason
enough alone for me to go check around
yeah yeah okay so I was looking at the
lineup and I would really like to see
Jessie where I love her yeah she's
totally I was surprised to see her on
there because she doesn't really fit the
EDM hip-hop rock anything she just is
such a phenomenal voice and she's funny
I've seriously more she's hilarious you
guys so if you ever see her I was so
glad you mention that because I do love
Jessie where she has a beautiful voice
oh she's from the UK right she's an
artist um okay so I'm gonna check her
out guys that's all the time we have for
and if you can't make it to Coachella
like Sophie mentioned don't worry
they'll be live-streaming uh some select
performances on Coachella's website as
well as their YouTube channel off
XM is also launching Coachella radio for
anyone driving in the car
they'll have performances backstage
interviews and more from India and of
course be sure to follow at
Entertainment Tonight and @d director on
Instagram I'm taking over et's Instagram
stories on Saturday for Beyonce and the
whole day I'm gonna take you guys inside
the festival because it is a lot of fun
um thank you so much for watching
thinking you guys for joining me I did
this anchor desk there was a lot of yous
to get to and we all we see all your
congratulatory notes for Chloe you guys
thank you so much for more on Chloe's
birth and all that exclusive source
reporting we just gave you head over to
ET online.com are you guys I'm gonna be
at Coachella tomorrow so no new daily
Denny but we I'll be back on Monday to
report back on what I saw if I could
live to tell the tale all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you